why does this YouTuber keep getting
recommended to me what's up Gamers today
I'm going to see what happens if you
throw 10,000 knives at a group of living
humans I mean he's kind of annoying
right oh my god he has a lot of
subscribers don't forget to hit like And
subscribe or else I'll throw some more
knives at people let's go see what his
earliest videos look
like huh hi internets I just wanted to
talk about Mario is he's Italian wow
there used to be such a youthful
innocence in his eyes Maybe YouTube Just
does this to everyone grinds a person's
hopes and dreams into views I just love
doing this even if nobody's watching but
I would sell my soul for more views just
so you guys are clear okay